not specific grants for white males what
specific what should that be why why
should there be they have higher suicide
rates that could possibly be one reason
and then maybe because all the
Privileges
excuse me my brothers are white males so
I don't I don't I'm giving you another
but I'm saying I'm saying I've had I've
had two brothers that tried to commit
suicide and I'm saying it's not they
didn't try to commit suicide because and
I'm not sorry I don't try to bring in
personal situations I shouldn't do that
but but like it's not because like they
they were thinking oh I have privileges
it's because life can be hard as a man
there's there's a lot of privileges
offered to women that men do not get and
I'm giving you examples but it's like
white men and why they should be getting
no no I said I said this is a privilege
that women get that men don't often get
and